peter ducey you guys know peter ducey
over at fox news he's an actual
journalist it's so refreshing not to
have to stretch my fingers and do this
when i say journalist around fox news is
peter ducey well he asked
jen saki yesterday if they would support
an independent special counsel uh
because now the hunter biden laptop
thing even though it was just a
processing error on the part of twitter
yeah it turned out to be real a lot of
stories about hunter biden servicing
this week so to ensure the independence
of the investigation would the president
support the appointment of a special
counsel
well first the president has never had a
conversation with the department of
justice about any investigations into
any member of his family he said that
during the campaign and he will continue
to abide by that so i'd point to the
department of justice for any additional
steps they would take they would make
those decisions independently is there
any concern that they're not going to be
necessarily seen as being able to make
the decisions independently if the white
house chief of staff is out saying that
the president is confident his son did
not break the law
well that's something the president has
said and certainly we would echo but in
the same answer to that question peter
during an interview this week on abc ron
clain also said the justice department
is independent and they will make their
own decisions
i don't think it's overstating it to say
that this could take down the
administration something is going on
here
a major
big tech media company censored a story
that we all know is now true this the
stuff that's on the laptop the emails
and why hunter biden was involved with
ukrainian energy companies and whether
money was going up to the big guy
meaning biden on top of whatever else he
was doing smoke and crack in the
pictures and all of that stuff
this is bad this is bad and if it is
being referred to the justice department
which is what saki's saying it's kind of
funny that saki's quitting her job at
the same time right we talked about that
yesterday saki's going over to msnbc
she's going to continue to be a paid
liar but she's just not going to do it
for the administration anymore she's
going to do it over on msnbc so she kind
of sees the writing on the wall and
something seems a little fishy about all
of this uh ducey continued to ask saki
some stuff
and the president has said that he never
spoke to his son about his overseas
business dealings is that still the case
yes
good
that's pretty uh straightforward there
saki you're saying yes but had never
spoke to his son about his business
healings think about how nonsensical
this is really think about this for a
second
hunter biden has no experience doing
anything in the energy sector he was a
crack addict artist
he was then getting paid
millions of dollars
by an energy company in ukraine why was
he getting paid that money if they
wanted to find a crack addict uh artist
they could have gone to the streets of
seattle and picked up anybody but they
picked up the vice president's son do
you think it possibly was because i know
is this is this alex jones level stuff
but do you think it's possible that a
ukrainian energy company that wants
certain things done they want certain
deals passed they want certain people in
certain positions right
um do you think they might be like hey
could we pay the president's crack
addict son who has no experience doing
anything so we'll give him a whole bunch
of money
so that maybe he will have some ability
to get his dad to do something what
jensaki just said right there first off
they're saying that's all just not true
no he actually was qualified for the job
just not true but what gensake said
there is no biden has never had a
conversation about that with his son so
he's ne so joe biden and hunter biden
have never talked about hunter biden's
work that's pretty crazy
uh any of you that are out there that
have fathers or any of you are that are
out there that are fathers is there
literally any person on earth that has
never talked to their father or their
son about what they do for a living but
apparently that's what's happened with
the old confused guy and the crack
addict
i should write a children's book the old
confused guy and the crack addict that's
going to be my next children's book uh
anyway this thing stinks this thing
stinks to high health and i don't know
i'm not a private investigator i'm just
not an idiot so that's why i'm talking
about it i don't think you're going to
get that on cnn